план сесії у нас такий
Дякую
план сесія У нас такий ми спершу з вами
познайомимося я розкажу трошки про свій
досвід потім ми Розберемося що таке
основа тексту І чому ми так комунікації
надважливо коли ви працюєте з текстом
потім попрактикуємося із перекладом з
ділової мови на розмовну і розберемо по
правилах хорошого тексту а також я
поділюся особливостями текстів текстів
для соцмереж 6 пункт це поки що секрет А
в кінці я дам вам невелике домашнє
завдання щоб ви могли його
практикуватися із тими
правилами і знаннями Які ви отримали на
цьому воркшопі сесія триватиме приблизно
90 хвилин Можливо ми впораємося швидше
але Я розраховую на те що ви будете
активні так як ви вже зайшли і
привіталися дуже вам дякую Я сподіваюся
що ми з вами класно попрацюємо готуйтеся
коментувати тому що у нас будуть
невеличкі практичні вправи в яких треба
бути брати участь
і
розкажу спершу трошки про себе Мене
звати Олена Міщенко Я вже 6 років працюю
у сфері діджитого маркетингу і
комунікації але починали свій шлях з
копірайтингу спершу як фрілансер писала
статті на замовлення потім в агенціях в
штаті І зараз я більше працюю
комунікаційна цим бренду профтех проте
все ж таки дуже багато часу приділяє
саме саме роботі із текстом за друге
вищу освіту Я клінічний психолог і
взагалі цікавляться науками і різними
підходами до навчання тому сподіваюся що
це воркшоп не тільки буде цікавим для
вас і корисним а ще й добре
запам'ятається
Отже текст
все починається з тексту будь-яка
рекламна компанія відеогра білборд
книжка серіал публікація у соцмережах
Текст - це фундамент без якого не може
обійтися жодна комунікація але без чого
не може обійтися текст
без мети
цей термін ми так комунікація вперше
зустріла на психологічному тренінгу зі
здоровою чи нетоксичної комунікації і
він означає доволі просту річ перш ніж
висловити свою думку Щось сказати Треба
поставити собі питання з якою метою Я
хочу це зробити і на який результат Я
взагалі розраховую яка мета цієї
комунікації і це саме питання потрібно
ставити коли ви пишете будь-який текст І
це дуже дуже важливо якщо ви відвідували
наш попередній вебінар ви вже були
знайомі з моєю концепцією комунікації в
режимі турботи це означає що не потрібно
створювати контент заради контенту
заради просто наповнення сторінки а
потрібно піклуватися про читача і
готувати контент який
закриває якось практично або
інформаційну потребу
запис перший з інфосесії До речі я на
Ютубі Я запрошую його передивлятися він
не дублює інформацію яка буде на цьому
воркшопі Отже перш ніж почати текст
потрібно визначити мету вашої
комунікації
Навіщо читачу це знати
загалом коли ми говоримо про комунікацію
в контексті саме освіти
є дві основні мети перша - це
проінформувати надати читачу тобто
випускникам потенційним вступникам їхнім
батькам бізнесом та іншим стоять
холдером що необхідно інформацію і друге
друга мета другий пріоритет це заохотити
їх забрати саме ваш заклад освіти
але оскільки часу у нас сьогодні
обмаль для того щоб покрити такий
величезний пластик інформації ми
все-таки будемо концентруватися на
Першому пріоритеті а саме я з
проінформувати так щоб читач Зрозумів
все дуже правильно і все як ми мали на
увазі без жодних упереджень і
двозначності
і в цьому є також
сенс чому ми концентруємося саме на
першому пріоритеті а не на другому тому
що він насправді цілком самостійний
проростає і доступна комунікація вона
добре працює на заохочення вступників до
вашого профтеху сама по собі тоді як
просто
креативні заклики вступати саме ваш про
всех і
комунікація про те чому вступники мають
обирати саме вас якщо вона
не інформує у простому і зрозумілому
форматі вона не буде ефективним
Отже що ми маємо як робочим матеріал -
це сухі ділові накази Від міністерства
написані діловою мовою
і наша аудиторія Зазвичай це підлітки та
їхні батьки які цією мовою навряд чи
розмовляють Отже Наша задача стати
такими собі перекладачами і до нас ця
інформація до нашої аудиторії зрозуміло
їм мова
на екрані скріншот з наказом
міністерства Я зараз його зачина-
зачитаю максимально експресивним голосом
Щоб ви могли точно зрозуміти моє
ставлення до цього тексту
порядок прийому для здобуття вищої
фахової передвищує та професійної
професійно-технічної освіти осіб які
проживають на тимчасово окупованій
території Автономної Республіки Крим та
місто Севастополя тимчасово окуповані
території окремих районів Донецької та
Луганської областей території населених
пунктів на лінії зіткнення
чи можна сказати те саме але в 5 разів
коротше і в 10 разів зрозуміліше
ми можемо сказати що це вступ для
жителів тимчасового окупованих територій
і населених пунктів на лінії зіткнення
звучить набагато простіше правда Я з
вами обов'язково поділюся правилами
написання текстів але трохи пізніше А
зараз пропоную спробувати побути
перекладачами не знаючи теорії наш мозок
краще запам'ятовує коли спочатку
страждає над вирішенням проблеми а потім
знаходиться Краще або легше рішення або
навіть готову відповідь тому алгоритм
роботи у нас буде такий
ось невеличка вирізка із наказу
Міністерства я дам хвилинку на те щоб ви
написали у коментарі ваш варіант цього
тексту як його можна написати інакше
простіше для вашої аудиторії потім я
читаю вголос ваші варіанти ваші
коментарі і пропоную свій варіант
І ми рухаємося до наступного до
наступної цитати таких цитат буде три
готові
у вас зараз є хвилинка на те щоб
запропонувати свій варіант цього тексту
дуже сподіваюся що ви прокоментуєте
коментуєте клас
супер є варіанти допомагають подати
заяву консультуємо та допомагаємо
звернись до нас Ми допоможемо оформити
твої документи допомагають оформити
заяву допомагають оформити декларацію
консультація при подачі декларації
допоможемо оформленню документів надають
допомогу ми ж вам не треба цей воркшоп і
так добре знаєте все супер дуже багато
коментарів Клас Я рада що ви такі
активні мій варіант такий
консультують і допомагають оформити
заяву
тому що нам потрібно все-таки сказати що
це про консультації і тому що
консультація допомоги це все-таки дві
різні послуги правильно тобто Одна
справа - це відповісти на запитання а
інша справа допомогти там з оформленням
саме документи тому це Потрібно
зауважити коли ми скорочуємо текст
важливо також не втрачати якусь частину
його сенсу
Добре давайте рухаємося далі
ну на це я дам дві хвилинки подумати Бо
чесно кажучи мені треба було хвилин це
щоб прочитати це і в голові перекласти
на розмовну мову
а вже я перший коментарі
оформлюємо документи надаємо
рекомендації вступникам надають допомогу
при підготовці документів для вступу
допомагаємо вступити у навчальний заклад
подання документів вступників До
закладів освіти
допоможемо пройти всі етапи до вступу
організовують прийом документів на вступ
добре
консультація та рекомендація при вступі
на закладів освіти організовуємо роботу
ой-ой загубила організовуємо роботу в
оформленні документів для вступу чи
заявника вступних випробувань
проконсультуємо проступ у будь-які
заклади освіти це добре
оформляють документи на вступ до запиту
оформлення документів Проведення
вступних випробувань та надання
рекомендації добре
Так мій варіант такий організовують
ступні Випробування допомагають у
допомагають з оформленням документів і
вибором закладу для вступу тобто знову
Ми не скорочуємо це до мінімуму що
повністю
втратити всю інформацію нам потрібно
залишатися конкретними
Перелічити те саме що перелічено в
тексті але зробити це простіше
зрозуміліше
і останній трошки легше Давайте так як
тижня Мені дуже приємно
так ще є перші коментарі
так надають інформацію про навчання Ой
ви так швидко пишете і не встигаю на
підготовчих курсах консультація по
підготовчих курсах надають допомогу при
необхідності навчання на підготовчий
курсах
пропонуємо підготовчі курси
консультуючись до навчання на
підготовчих курсах
[музика]
консультування абітурієнтів щодо
навчання
так добре Мій варіант це консультують
про наявні підготовчі курси на які можна
записатися
добре
Прекрасна робота
Я дуже рада що ви активні і нас попереду
ще декілька таких практичних вправ тому
я сподіваюся що ми ще з вами попрацюємо
отже
Давайте подумаємо що змінилося Напишіть
будь ласка коментарі Взагалі що ви
побачили які зміни відбулися із текстом
чому саме він яким він став
став простим
доступнішим спрощенням зрозумілим чи
табельним
людяний доступний для розуміння
доступним чіткий короткий зрозумілий
коротшим
коротше простіше сформульована думка
легко ми зрозумілим
зрозумілим чи табельним позбувся
наукової термінології став зрозумілим
для нефахівця доступне для сприйняття
більш конкретним відхід від офіціозу
доступність лаконічність
конкретна думка
так по-перше
так став коротшим Ми забрали все зайве
всі реки уточнення деталі залишили
тільки найважливіше по-друге Ми
використовували прості і зрозумілі слова
які якими ми спілкуємось у повсякденному
житті без канцеляризмів і професійних
термінів хтось же зазначив Це ці терміни
в коментарях офіцерилось і канцелярит це
такий знаєте терміни і слова які
використовуються у більш у документо
оберті і такому діловому суховому
спілкуванні тому коли Справа доходить до
текстів у соціальних мережах і до
повсякденного спілкування вони
виглядають якось не натурально тому їх
потрібно уникати
і давайте повернемося до цього слайду
і розберемо його трошки детальніше Отже
ми змінили порядок прийому на здобуття
вищої на порядок прийому для здобуття ми
замінили одним словом вступ
Ми також скоротили перелік закладів
освіти у які можуть подавати документи
вступники тому що в принципі вони
перераховані всі тобто якби це наказ був
саме про вступ до про втехів Ми би мали
це зазначити У нашому тексті також Тобто
ми мали би сказати вступ до профтехів
для жителів тимчасово окупованих
територій Те саме стосується і переліку
територій тобто якби це був наказ саме
про вступ для жителів території
наприклад Автономної Республіки Крим то
ми мали також це зазначити У нашому
скороченому тексті тому що як я вже
сказала нам Важливо не тільки скоротити
і замінити слова більш простими а також
зберегти дуже важливий сенс щоб не
перекрутити цілком те що було сказано в
наказі
Отже правило перше як я вже сказала
скорочено все що можна скоротити але
важливо без втрати сенсу
не треба гнатися за тим щоб текст був
максимально короткий іноді переписаний
текст
зрозумілою мовою може виглядати навіть
довшим ніж на касу з міністерства тому
що деяка термінологія вона закриває
Наприклад одна довжина речення яке
потрібно буде розкласти розжувати і
пояснити аудиторії тому скорочуємо але
без фанатизму
ой нет і друге правило пам'ятаємо для
кого ми пишемо і використовуємо
зрозумілі слова
регулярно звіряйтеся Чи не надто це
складно Уявіть себе на місці читача
пофантазуйте згадайте себе коли ви були
підлітком це чи знали ви такі слова як
ви зараз використали в тексті чи легко
вам взагалі зрозуміти написано
також хочу зазначити що сучасні підлітки
взагалі мало читають у соціальних
мережах дуже популярний Snap content це
такі коротенькі дописи в яких мінімум
інформації які можна прочитати Буквально
за 10-15 секунд
а відео з Тік току якщо знаєте особливо
навчальні відео з Тік току там взагалі
два-три речення корисна інформація і
вони набирають мільйони лайків
переглядів і дуже користуються
популярністю серед молоді тому
зрозуміліше коротше простіше
розумієте ваша аудиторію і писати Саме
для неї це суперважливо тому що як ви
знаєте якщо вони не дочитають ваш пост
до кінця вони не дізнаються більше про
вас і відповідно не прийдуть подавати
заяву до вашого закладу
потренуємося готові писати коментарі
Як то кажуть я вам слово а ви мені 10
але навпаки я вам виведена на екран
зараз словосполучення знову такий із
наказів Міністерства А ви напишете в
коментарі їхній альтернативи тобто Як це
можна сказати простіше наприклад як би
це сказав підліток або просто не знаю
людина з вулиці готові поїхали документ
що посвідчує особу
паспорт паспорт паспорт паспорт паспорт
паспорт
id-картка id-картка
так паспорт або ID прекрасно
друге
стипендіальне забезпечення
стипендія стипендія гроші
чепуха
стипендія
так прекрасно Звісно що стипендія
стіпуха - це знаєте дуже я би сказала
трошки занадто розумована
все-таки звісно
студенти особливо використовують ці
слова але коли ми комунікуємо як заклад
освіти частіше за все ми використовуємо
все-таки більш такі
нейтральні слова без слентів і
жарганізмів наступне
строки проведення прийому на навчання
займе не навчання термін вступу строк
подачі документів вступна кампанія
вступна компанія дедлайн
термін навчання
термін навчання строк подачі документів
вступ початок
початок вступу
дуже багато варіантів мені дедлайн
сподобався дійсно
це запозичене слово але воно дуже
активно використовується зараз
можете його вільно включати у власну
комунікацію але моя пропозиція - це
строки вступної або строки вступної
кампанії
наступне не бюджетна корм конкурсна
пропозиція
контракт
варіанти конкурсу
Да там був дуже доречні коментар що
дедлайн - це
фінальна точка так Тобто це вже кінець
кінцева дата прийоми документів тому
[музика]
треба використовувати це зрозумінням
цього слова а не замість слова строки да
тому що строки це все-таки А якийсь
період від і долайн - це суто-кінцева
точка і так не бюджет на конкурсна
пропозиція так це простими словами
контракт
Ну і нарешті
профте
училище училище
училище заклад про освіти
училища
ми пропонуємо про втех тому що у нас
бренд профтех і
тому що це таке якщо ви знаєте пройшов
бренд професійно-технічної освіти так
створився бренд профтеху який зараз
комунікує зі сторінок
соціальних мережному сторінок
Міністерства освіти і науки тому замість
слів
ПТО
заклад
професійно-технічної освіти або училище
профтехучилище ми Радимо використовувати
профтех тому що він вже асоціюється з
таким стильним молодіжним рухом дизайном
І взагалі такими ідеями тому Ласкаво
просимо використовувати це в свої
комунікації теж
ваші овації Прекрасна робота Я дуже рада
що ви так активно коментуєте Дуже вам за
це дякую
правила третє Звісно що це не всі
правила хороших
хороших текстів пам'ятаєте яку мету ви
переслідуєте коли плануєте публікувати
конкретний текст
це про мету комунікації згадуємо наші
пріоритети найважливіше це
проінформувати надати всю необхідну
інформацію яка потрібна саме читачу не
вам на вашому закладу не начальство а
саме читачу вашій аудиторії тобто треба
подумати що ж вас читач а ваша аудиторія
буде шукати і надавати цю інформацію
добре рухаємось далі
помітили
правило 4 будьте уважні так цього слайду
тут немає і попереднє правило було під
номером 3 тому ретельно перечитуйте
власні тексти перевіряйте нумерації коми
одруківки видаляйте зайві абзации
пробіли Зберігайте послідовність
викладання це дуже важливо і правило
п'яте Розділяй і володарю Отже один пост
має відповідати на одне конкретне
питання не потрібно намішувати дуже
багато всього це правило трохи
перекликається з ідеєю коротких текстів
тобто краще опублікувати більше постів
але щоб кожен пост відповідав на якесь
одне конкретне з питань як вступити до
вашого про втеху випускникам 9-х класів
як вступити до вашого протеху
випускникам 11-х класів вступ для
окремий пост вступ для ВПО окремий пост
вступ для школярів окремо Все окремо
по-перше це зручно коли ви плануєте
контент Вам не потрібно думати
про те чим заповнити як публікувати
регулярно там 1 2 3 пости на тиждень
тому що ви
дробите інформацію Яку вам треба надати
І у вас вже є регуляльні послуги а
по-друге така маленька конкретна тема
закриває потребу якраз конкретно
цільовою аудиторії Тобто ви не
розпиляєтесь і її прочитаю саме той хто
цю інформацію шукає А якщо на цей пост
надійде хтось цю інформацію не хоче
знати він просто його пригортає і пройде
повз
і це про турботу про читача також
замість того щоб вчити вчитуватися у
лонгрід і шукати там інформацію
специфічно для себе якщо ти школяр а там
пост про вступ для всіх
все-таки зручніше коли є окремий
маленький коротенький постик
і аксіома яку я не втомлюся повторювати
краще не виходити з публікації взагалі
ніж опублікувати щось неякісне
безсенсовне порожнє тобто якщо у вашого
посту немає у вашого тексту Не
обов'язково це має бути дописи
соцмережах немає конкретної мети краще
його не публікувати навіть не витрачати
час на його на написання спершу
подумайте про мету а потім вже пишіть і
публікуйте цей допис
я детальніше пояснювала на попередньому
вебінарі то ми дуже раджу його
переглянути якщо ви його пропустили
здогадалися що це означає
так мою любов до котиків але також
знаєте як на те що ми зараз будемо
практикуватися ми з вами розглянули 5
основних правил написання хорошого
тексту І тепер маємо їх закріпити на
практиці
я взяла ці тексти із ваших соціальних
мереж ви коли реєструвалися на цей
вебінар Я просила вас заповнити додати
посилання на ваші соцмережі але я
заховала на важливе ваших про втехів щоб
зберегти анонімність зараз практика така
Ви читаєте Цей текст і швидко і коротко
пишете буквально одне речення що в цьому
тексті Можна було б покращити згідно з
тими п'ятьма правилами які ми з вами вже
розглянемо і я дивлюся ваші коментарі і
потім коментую відповідно до результатів
давайте хвилинка
зменшити кількість тексту трішки
скоротити спростити
оклику скоротити
запрошуємо на віртуальну екскурсію нашим
закладом
Це був один з моїх коментарів так
Запрошуємо віртуальну подорож
дуже добре друге абзац не потрібний
скоротити скоротити
друге абзац не треба додати смайли
ознайомитись з професією написати
простішими словами
шановні вступники пропоную вам все
стільки віртуальна подорож
закладами зручний для вас час дуже добре
автобологія
застосувати абревіатуру
спростити текст
дуже класні коментарі
дуже класні коментарі Дякую
щодо абревіатури Хочу зазначити що
насправді Я би не радила тому що це
якраз про офіційоз да тобто якщо ми
спрощуємо спростити скоротити це не
тільки замінити там три слова
абревіатуру з трьох букв це про те щоб
звучати
зрозумілими для нашої аудиторії тому
мої коментарі це замінити закладі
загальної середньої освіти взагалі на
школи-інтернати якщо є або щось інше
тобто конкретизувати бо ви так само
випускників закладів середньої освіти
може не бути готовою асоціації із цим
словосполученням
а от якщо ви скажете випускники шкіл це
одразу оп це я Я випускник школи
дуже класний був коментар так Запрошуємо
вас здійснити віртуальну
Це просто трошки коротше і воно якось
звучить гостинніше
державним навчальним закладом тут все
добре
взагалі я би не скорочувала цей пост у
нього оптимальна довжина
просто для соцмереж можуть бути
будь-якою довжини в залежності від того
що вам потрібно сказати
єдине що я би забрала слово унікально
тому що це такий собі моветон в
копірайтингу його потрібно
використовувати дуже обережно бо є
великий ризик звучати як знаєте це
ажіотажні рекламні ролики що продають
дешеві продукти шалено високі ціні а
потім пропонують вам раптово дуже велику
знижку щоб уникнути подібних асоціацій з
чимось не дуже якісним слово унікально
краще не використовувати взагалі
і щодо
матеріально-технічним потенціалом
закладу освіти
його краще уточнити тобто створити якусь
картинку знаєте в уяві читача
Як думаєте чи багато асоціацій виникає у
школяра чи у їхньому батьків
на оце матеріально-технічний потенціал
закладу освіти жодних а от ми могли б
сказати побачити аудиторії лабораторії
місця інструменти для практичних занять
і це вже читаючи добре зрозуміє про що
йдеться мова тому замість того щоб
просто видаляти другий абзац я обиратила
його просто конкретизувати
тобто зробити його зрозумілим розказати
що саме віртуальна подорож дасть
випускникам школи тому що у першому
абзаці Ми запрошуємо але навіщо
і друге вже це якраз має відповісти на
це питання з якою метою школяр або
випускник школи має подивитися цей
тур пройти цей тур і також у будь-який
зручний для вас час це також краще
скорочувати або у будь-який час або у
зручний для вас час
просто зайве видалити
добре рухаємося далі
наступний пост
Чекаю на ваші коментарі
так доречний коментар що це якщо це
офіційний сайт то так Звісно що можна
залишити але в контексті соціальних
мереж краще все-таки публікувати
простою мовою
Що чесно кажучи Мій особистий моє
особисте ставлення до
офіційних якихось текстів на сайті що
вони теж мають бути простими тобто у вас
мають бути документи
там де все офіційна мова детально
прописано щоб у людини був доступ до цих
документів вона в будь-який момент могла
перейти до них і уточнити необхідну
інформацію але вся загально комунікація
може бути спрощена
такою людиною простою
другий абзац перше речення зайве
скоротити осучаснити непогано написано
згодна
згодна ми насправді це допис дуже
сподобався
поміняти абзаци місцями
змінити абзаци місцями
дуже слушні коментарі
про суд два рази
нічого не змінювати
Останнє речення зайве
так і ще будуть якісь зауваження
прекрасно коментар вам і тобі
так
так чудова робота ви такі уважні так
мені це допис дуже сподобався
[музика]
єдине що я би перенесла так само оцю от
фразу ви завжди це запитання на початок
тому що це якраз таки знаєте гачочок для
того щоб привертати увагу читача і я
його захочувати далі
тому так я би його винесла в цілому я би
теж пост не сильно змінювали Звісно що
його можна текст взагалі можна
покращувати нескінченності але як то
кажуть навіщо
І на що так дуже хотілося звернути увагу
це
звернення до читача
по-перше Ви з великої літери це вже
вважається старомодним ви звісно можете
це використовувати знаєте як таку
ізюминку родзиночку вашого саме закладу
вашої комунікації але ну все одно це не
дуже пасує закладу освіти як на мене це
моє суб'єктивне враження
тому загалом копірайтери редактор буде
зазвичай пишуть ви з маленької літери І
не використовують Ви з великої але що
набагато важливіше це те що в одному
тексті ми маємо звертатися до читача в
якийсь один спосіб тобто або на ти або
на ви в ідеалі щоб Вся ваша комунікація
була в таких єдиний спосіб або на ти або
на ви але
іноді це важко зробити тому що у вас
можуть бути різні аудиторії І наприклад
на сайті ви можете звертатися на ви в
Фейсбуці на ви А в Інстаграмі на ти і це
нормально але ще найважливіше це
слідкувати щоб в одному в межах одного
тексту не було плутанини і перескакувань
на ти на ви
добре це текст Давайте ви так класно
коментуєте
якщо мова йде про професію то писати їх
відповідно до ліцензії або ж просто
Перелічити професію на повторюючи
однакові Так це службовий коментар щодо
написання професії відповідно до
ліцензії це буде більше Професіонал який
якого Ми намагаємося уникнути тому так
краще спрощувати і не повторювати а вже
повний перелік професій розміщувати на
вашому сайті з
написаних відповідно до ліцензії щоб
вступивши міг вибрати А у публікації для
соціальних мереж скоротили і все і не
треба там уточнювати зайве зайвий раз
думка розділилася
набагато інформації
інфографіка сприймається краще
скоротити
коротка та ясна інформація
прибрати повтори
посилання на сайт навчального закладу
Ми вже в них немає сайту
але звісно було би добре
інформацію дублюється
друкарські огріхи
забрати червоний колір
дизайн неприварною
будучи ще коментарі по цій
публікації
знову ж я вас Зліва і тебе справа
слушний коментар
це суб'єктивна дизайнер дуже
ми конкретно зауважуємо
Добре дякую вам за коментарі вони дійсно
корисні а Вибачте тут є сайт я його
просто замазала
з точки зору анонімності
писать повторює назву
закладу
так ваші коментарі доречні і мені
подобається що ви використовуєте
інформацію які ви тільки що навчилися
для того щоб буквально на попередньому
слайді Там дійсно тут з лівого на
картинці звернення на ви в тексті допису
звернення над тим щодо об'єму інформації
згодна Можна було б не дублювати те саме
що на картинці у тексті
але мені насправді цей допис дуже
сподобався тому що він структурований
картинка привертає увагу те що вона
зроблена в Червоній кольоровій Гамі це
якраз привертає увагу читача це не
означає що потрібно робити всі дописи в
такі кольорові гами але інколи Вони
працюють добре
єдине що що стосується картинки я би
змінила
цей надпис Оскільки ми знаємо як важливо
досягти успіху в житті я би його
скоротила або прибрала би зовсім якщо
скорочувати я би залишила шлях до
успішної кар'єри тому що успіх у житті -
це ви не можете гарантувати
успіху в житті тому що життя - це дуже
така знаєте що широке поняття і для всіх
успіх у житті означає різні речі а успіх
у кар'єрі
в принципі можна не те щоб гарантувати
але сказати що це перший крок до успіху
у кар'єрі на кар'єрному шляху але що у
мене є зауваження щодо
оцих трьох закликів на початку посту це
актуальна вакансія сучасна професія Для
тебе А з точки зору з SMM так
маркетингу соціальних мереж це працює Як
привертання увагу так великі літери
слова актуального вакансія знаку оклику
вони стовідсотково працюють на
повернення уваги Тобто це провокує
людину відкритий допис і прочитати що ж
там таке актуальне Я таке не
використовую тому що по-перше на вся
інформація вона є такою важливою а
по-друге вони все-таки теж є таке
асоціації тому що дуже часто після цих
слів актуально і ще щось іде реклама
і вона не завжди реклама якісних якихось
продуктів але іноді цей це можна
використовувати не заперечую але на чому
хотілося б знову звернути увагу на слові
вакансія тому що це не вакансія Я
перейшла на сайт і подивилася що це
заклик вступити в профтех
і дуже важливо не обманювати очікування
читача як би вам не хотілося привернути
увагу ваша задача вибудовувати довірливі
стосунки Якщо ви кажете що це вакансія
то у вас має бути вакансія а не
запрошення на вступ
повчитися і здобути якусь професію
тому що коли людина побачила що це
вакансія перейшла вакансію не знайшла і
у неї фрустрація
обманули
навіщо з маніпулювали такого ніхто не
любить ставлення коли то людина
маніпулюють тому краще уникати бо це вже
закладає якийсь негативний фундамент у
ваші стосунки і це може вплинути
негативно у майбутньому на вибір людиною
закладу для вступу
щось там десь знаєте воно буде в
інтуїції якось підказувати що не треба
йти в той заклад Щось мені там не
подобається Вона може не Пам'ятати про
ваш допис але воно збережеться тому
ми привертаємо увагу але joom робимо це
чесно і прямолінійно не створюємо
двосмислених посилань не обманюємо і не
намагаємося ввести вона в оману
але в будь-якому разі Я вам дуже дякую
за ваші коментарі
Це просто прекрасно
і остання пост давайте він коротенький
швиденько зараз
напишемо
впливових коментар про розмите Текст це
можливо через скріншот
додаток qr-код
знаєте для соцмереж це дуже такий
не факт Він не завжди добре працює ну
Уявіть собі qr-код сканується з камерою
камерою смартфону І якщо людина гортає
соцмережі зі смартфону і бачить qr-код
що вона має зробити Вона ж не може
Перейти за qr-кодом
тому Про це варто пам'ятати коли ви
думаєте додаток qr-код qr-код це добре
розмістити на вашому сайті наприклад у
ваших закладах освіти роздрукувати їх і
наклеїти десь на дошку оголошень чи ще
кудись або там на листівки візитівки
додаток qr-коди А на картинках в
соцмережі точно немає сенсу
так дивлюся ваші коментарі
не бажаючих а охочих
не вистачає вартості навчання
виділити шрифтом деякі фрази
це публікація з Інстаграму в Інстаграмі
немає можливості Гратися зі шрифтами на
жаль тому все що ми можемо зробити це
додати якийсь Смайлики і розділити на
Абзац
вартість навчання поміняти місцями перше
друге абзац
не маєте на малювання
Валентина підготувала
альтернативний пост
прекрасно
дуже хороший пост
тільки Зверніть увагу що звернення на Ви
краще робити з маленької літери я про це
зазначила на попередніх слайдах
все гарно чітко то Зрозуміло От я так
думаю якщо чесно
Як то кажуть дійсно можна тексти правити
дані скінченності Можна було б додати
сюди більше інформації А можна було б
розказати детальніше про вартість
навчання про терміни навчання але в
цілому Насправді це дуже класний пост
якраз ідеальний пост для Інстаграму
обираю робітничу професію зроби свій
внесок у відбудову України
можна конечно прибиратися до емодзів
всередині речень їх краще виносити або
на початок речення абзацу саме абзацу
або на кінець абзацу всередину краще їх
не ставити і там на відсутність пробілів
але в цілому
це хороший текст
І знаєте що я тут виділила зелененьким
знаєте що це таке
в цьому є спеціальна термінологія
комунікація
Валентина дякую З меню це було до
навчання А ну прекрасно було до навчання
так звернення Я чекаю на ваші коментарі
я впевнена хтось знає відповідь на це
запитання
те що виділила зеленим - це
такий
маркетинговий прийом копіранський прийом
у нього є своя назва Можливо хтось її
знає
слоган заклик
заклик до дії
заклик до дії Так я побачила те що я
шукала і ми переходимо до наступного
слайду це заклик до дії або call to
Action або citya як це зазвичай
називають маркетологи і кооператори це
невід'ємна частина будь-якої комунікації
і найголовніше - це якраз реалізація
мети вашого тексту
заклик до дії має бути в кінці кожного
тексту тобто якщо у вашого тексту є мета
ви її маєте реалізувати в кінці через
заклик до дії
я вам дам формулу заклику до дії але
пізніше з першого дивимося на текст і
пишемо в коментарі чи є тут заклик до
дії Як ви думаєте що немає
є я є
я не маю я не маю я не маю думка
розділилася знову ж таки я вам хочу
сказати що тут немає закладу дії
Чекаємо тебе це не заклади дій
так дивимося тут чи є тут заклик до дії
Ну тут Одна думка
Одноголосно немає і останній
хтось намалював на екрані
ой нет Намалюйте на екрані будь ласка
Олена Толкай будь ласка Намалюйте на
екрані подивіться у нас тут вибачте будь
ласка Намалюйте будь ласка на екрані
Дякую
Так я зараз
[музика]
закрию презентацію
так добре І тут так на третьому пості у
третьому пості нарешті є заклик до дії
зробити перший крок в успішне майбутнє
вже разом з
якимось закладами освіти
Саме так тому що формула cti це зроби
щось зараз має бути обов'язково дієслово
із закликом підпишись прокоментуй
навчись купи лайкни подивись
чекаємо на тебе це такий Це запрошення
це не заклик до дії він не стимулює
людину здійснити якусь дію а Наша задача
якраз просто малювати тому що це вже
було перевірено і доказано дуже багато
разів
що коли ми Закликаємо людину а що
зробити вона це збільшує відсоток
вірогідність того що вона це зробить що
вона дійсно передає клікне лайкне і так
далі дуже багато блогерів дуже багато
копірайтерів проводили експерименти коли
вони публікували пости однакові
в усьому але відрізнялося тільки
наявністю заклику до дії і постарів
закликом до дії наприклад лайкне або
прокоментуй набирали більше лайків і
коментарів тому обов'язково їх додавайте
до своїх текстів
і ми з вами плавно переходимо до текстів
для соціальних мереж
всі таблиці я підготувала основну
інформацію яка стосується цих текстів
тобто є ліміти тексту які визначають
самі платформи Тобто ви не можете
опублікувати текст який виходить за межі
цих лімітів
також є хештеги хештеги - це більше
рекомендації маркетологів тобто
більшість платформ немає лімітів по
хештегам але краще використовувати не
більше 3-5 Ну можна там знаєте
плюс-мінус 2 але без фанатизму можна
взагалі не використовувати хештеги це не
є такою
складовою комунікації хоча радять
маркетологи додавати їх до своїх
публікацій Я також навігаційні хештеги -
це Telegram бо вони працюють або в
телеграмі всі інші хештеги не мають
ніякої ніякої цінності навігаційні
хештеги - це коли ви складаєте створюєте
наприклад якусь рубрику
і
за цією рубрикою закріплюєте якийсь
хештег тому коли людина заходить на вашу
сторінку в телеграм на ваш канал і
клікаю на цей хештег Вона може побачити
всі публікації з цим хештегом Але чесно
кажучи я би на цим не заморочувалася
можна в принципі не користуватися і
Зверніть увагу на Посилання у текстах в
соціальних мережах тому що не на всіх
платформах посилання активні
наприклад в Інстаграмі якщо ви
публікуєте посилання в дописі в дописі
до картинки Воно не буде клікабельним
тобто людина не зможе клікнути і
відкрити в браузері ваше посилання вона
не зможе також його скопіювати якщо вона
користується смартфоном саме додатком на
смартфоні тому в Instagram посилання
немає сенсу додавати
tiktok в залежності від країни в якій ви
знаходитеся Він дозволяє час від часу
ставити якісь посилання Але вони у нього
також є обмеження поплавок формах тобто
будь-яке посилання наприклад посилання
на ваш сайт ви в опис до відео на
тіктоці додати не зможете але ви можете
додати посилання на ваш сайт у описі
профілю що в tiktok що в Instagram
І звісно не потрібно додавати посилання
на картинки Вони 100% не будуть
клікабельні і це просто займає текст
займає простір на вашій картинці
але попри те що у соціальних мереж є
обмеження і вони не дуже маленькі
все-таки рекомендовано об'єм посту до
1000 символів
такий об'єм інформації легко
сприймається і більше вірогідність що
цей допис читає до кінця
в будь-якому документі Word чи Google
doc є функція рахування символів десь
там в інструментах є можна знайти але
стандартно - це півсторінки тексту або
або
менше Але я би радила все-таки робити
коротші дописи тобто 1000 символів це
такий собі вважається лонгрід Да дуже
довгий допис для соціальних мереж
тому краще
писати менше 200 500 символів
оптимальний формат
і декілька порад щодо форматування
тексту
додавайте більше простору між абзацами
обираєте пишіть короткими реченнями
короткими абзацами
[музика]
щоб це не виглядало знаєте таким
суцільним текстом ви можете самі зараз
побачите Напевно що текст який
знаходиться зліва все-таки він
сприймається легше
тут ще пара прикладів того як робити
коротенький і легкий для сприймання
тексту Коли вони бачите такий текст у
соціальних мережах його більше Ну якось
його хочеться прочитати А коли ви бачите
текст який такий знаєте суцільним
полотнам
У деяких людей може
паніка бути О боже я не хочу тут читати
і прогорнув
і текст на картинках хочу дати декілька
порад текст на картинках має бути
мінімальним і мінімальний Це не про
розмір шрифту на картинці А про
кількість тексту
добре дивіться щоб текст довше добре
читався зі смартфону пам'ятайте читачі
переглядають стрічку соцмереж зазвичай з
маленького екрану телефону якщо вони не
можуть швидко прочитати інформацію Вони
не будуть її збільшувати
вони просто і пригортають тому
будь ласка
Слідкуйте за тим щоб текст був
читабельним
і точно не так
так напевно виглядає людина яка
намагається це прочитати на боках
це приклади якраз текстом на картинках
ви бачите все одно тут пара абзаців
теж є дуже важлива така стисла
інформація і старайтеся розміщувати
текст якось графічно щось замінювати в
тексті графічними елементами для того
щоб передати той самий сенс правильно
замість того щоб писати телеграми
Instagram Facebook можна змінити
іконками і так далі
думайте про це теж
Ні це не зовсім кінець воркшопу з
відповіддю на питання І що вам із цим
всім робити там відповідь проста більше
практикуватися І що це ваше рятівне коло
читаємо текст вибрали найцікавіше зі
спільного та роз малою академою наук про
стереотипи у сфері профтехосвіти
спілкування була Ірина Шумик
і що
гортаю картки щоб дізнатися про
креативність у робітничих професій
реальний рівень зарплат випускників
протестів і цінність такої освіти
сьогодні
І що це перевірка чи додає речення абзац
чи розділ якусь цінність для читача чи
досягли ви мети своєї комунікації чи є
заклик до дії тобто І що це такий прийом
копірайтерський чим частіше ви задаєте
собі це питання Коли ви пишете текст тим
простішим тим доступнішим Та якіснішим
він буде в результаті
Ну і на цьому У мене все Я вам дуже
дякую за активність ви були дуже активні
я була вражена і дуже приємно здивована
Дякую вам за це ми з вами впоралися
майже за годину і навіть маємо трошки
часу відповісти на коментарі
але з першого
ваші Овація ви переробили Прекрасну
роботу я дуже вами пишаюся
і у мене є для вас домашнє завдання
після того як ми пройдемося по
домашньому завданню я відповім на
запитання у коментарях
домашнє завдання - це придумати два sita
або два заклики для дій які ви можете
використовувати у своїх дописах
спробуйте бути креативними але
пам'ятайте що все-таки краще бути
простішими і зрозумілими ніж
красномовними і зарозами
друге завдання - це написати два пости
на будь-яку тему Я не хочу вас
обмежувати темою оберіть ту яка у вас є
вже в контент-плані або І про яку ви
хочете прокомунікувати або навіть
Візьміть пост який ви написали раніше і
хочете тепер його покращити орієнтуючись
на знання Які ви отримали На цьому
воркшопі і обов'язково на початку
кожного тексту напишіть ми ту
комунікації одним реченням коротко там
пояснити особливості вступу на весь 9
класу тут є всі приклади ваші тексти я
пропоную
підвантажити у форму яка буде за
посиланням ми надійшло на це посилання
вам на електронну адресу ви просто
скопіюєте у необхідні поля ваші тексти я
їх потім конвертую у табличку
передивлюся і Наступного тижня ми
зустрічаємося знову з усіма бажаючими на
фідбек сесію
буде проходити Таким чином я виберу
декілька текстів в залежності від того
скільки їх буде в залежності від того
наскільки об'ємними будуть мої коментарі
до цих текстів ну це буде там не знаю 3
і 5 можливо 10 текстів і я їх дуже
ретельно прокоментую як я це робила з
попередніми
елементами так маленькими цими постиками
я дам більш Розгорнуті коментарі як ці
тексти Можна було б покращити не тільки
з точки зору того що ми вже пройшли На
цьому воркшопі А і можливо додам якісь
додаткові дам додаткові поради
так і на фідбек сесії через через
тиждень ви зможете задати ще якісь
питання Які у вас виникнуть А вони
скоріш за все виникнуть Коли ви будете
працювати над текстом тому що запитання
завжди приходять під час роботи
так ну у мене все
презентація буде у вас на пошті десь
через годинку Після
цієї зустрічі
да Всім дякую колеги презентація і
відеозапис буде у вас на пошті тому
в принципі Всім дякую за увагу Дякую за
величезну активність
До зустрічі в наступну середу віра у нас
є ще час трошки відповісти на питання в
принципі так якщо у вас є питання
задавайте я бачила там одне питання було
ось воно зараз надішлю олені питання
полягало чи доречно спрощувати назву
професію оголошення наприклад слюсар з
ремонту сільськогосподарських машин та
устаткування тракторист машиніст
сільського виробництва категорії А водій
автотранспортних засобів категорії с це
назва однієї професії
Я думаю є сенс тому що назва цієї
професії Це буде
просто
півсторінки тексту тому так старайтеся
скоротити настільки щоб це не зовсім
звузити так і втратити сенс залишити там
умовно там до 5 слів для того щоб людина
мала собі уявлення Але знову ж таки в
залежності від того де це оголошення має
бути тобто якщо ви його публікуєте в
соцмережах то є сенс зробити скорочено
версію а потім опублікувати
бюджетом наприклад на work.ua або де ви
там Це оголошення публікуєте вже повну
назву цієї професії якщо там немає
лімітів саме для цих назва в описі
тут було питання до чи мають дописи бути
лише профтех
по-домашці ну це дописи про вашу
які мають публікуватися у ваших закладах
освіти від імені ваших закладів освіти
тому так
дедлайн на виконання домашнього завдання
Ну надсилайте до бажано там до понеділка
вівторка
якщо там подивимося Я буду скоріш за все
дивитися і вибирати що прокоментувати у
понеділок і у вівторок
[музика]
Але можу переглянути якісь тексти і в
середу тому чим раніше тим краще але
сильно не поспішайте
також було прохання скинути посилання на
перший workshop ми скинемо в спільний
лист
додамо добре
дякую вам дуже дякую бачу що коментарі
більше немає Та всім